welcome back to new rock stars
spider-man 3 is
whipping open the mcu to a spider-verse
with cameos
by everyone from jamie foxx electro to
possibly even toby mcguire andrew
garfield kirsten dunst mj
past green goblins i guess everyone
except jk simmons hairpiece i'm eric
voss
and this is rogue theory the show that
brings you the
wildest nerdy hot takes on the topics
you can't stop arguing about
and with me today is the eddie brock's
who my peter parker tommy bechtold
hey all right we are phenomenal but it's
only because uh tommy likes to stand
beneath me in bell towers and just
collect whatever i'm dripping down
it's probably one of my favorite
pastimes
handfuls of voss oh boy uh
moving on briskly to a friend of the
show comedian and writer
jessica clemens welcome back jessica hi
do i
look like a news reporter because that's
what zach said before the show and now
i'm cons
i want to keep holding my hand up to my
headset if you need to switch over to
the uh telemarketing scheme you're
currently working on
by all means go for it make that money
okay thank you
and first time here on new rockstars
comedian writer owner of the best
possible middle name
john xavier miller welcome john thank
you for having me
i am excited to be here and i'm the best
xavier that you've had on this show
probably that's right and uh the best
xavier in the marvel world at the moment
because
uh yeah very slim competition welcome
the show we're so happy to have you here
man
so folks we're gonna spend this whole
episode on these new updates we've been
getting about spider-man 3
because there is really so much to
unpack just by this
little casting announcement it's so
confusing that there are so many
implications
so just to catch you up last week we
were all
let's see shocked to learn that the
third
mcu spider-man film coming next year the
follow-up too far from home
will feature jamie foxx as elektro the
actor himself confirmed it
and that of course is a character he
played in the
totally different spider-man universe
the amazing spider-man 2.
i went into how based on jk simmons
return as j jonah jameson and far from
home it seems like
sony is building toward a live-action
spider-verse
with past versions of characters now
appearing alongside tom holland
it's nuts so i want each of you to pitch
me how the plot of this movie is gonna
work
how and why are these spider verses
colliding
tommy why don't you start i believe we
are going to
see a trial the trial of peter parker
as spider-man for the murder of mysterio
uh and on that trial there is going to
be
a witness a young witness who was
traveling
abroad to london at the time and
happened to
actually see proof that could exonerate
peter parker aka spider-man for this
murder
that witness's name none other than
miles
morales i believe miles morales will be
introduced
as a witness for the defense that will
uh that will help to free
peter parker but then put miles morales
in the crosshairs
of uh anyone who would also wish
spider-man
harm now i believe we are gonna have
these uh
inter-dimensional spider-mans also
coming in spider-man's from other
universes spider-man's uh
the spider-verse as you said so i do
believe at a certain point
uh there is going to be a moment
when uh miles morales is also going to
acquire the spider-man powers similar to
the comics
or into the spider-verse movie he'll get
bit by a radioactive spider
or something along those lines uh and
what the ultimate the movie is going to
be about is a passing of the torch
and how tom holland's character is going
to accept
that you know uh there's a new
spider-man and maybe he can live a
normal life with mj
uh is through the wisdom of andrew
garfield and toby mcguire's spider-man
characters
who at this point i believe will have in
their stories have let go of the
spider-man mantle themselves so it's
going to be all about
returning home returning back to where
you were keeping
aunt may safe by by leaving the
spider-man mantle keeping
uh keeping mj safe by leaving the
spider-man mantle keeping ned safe by
leaving the spider-man mantle and
handing it over to a new
spider-man who he can still mentor and
by the way these people all have their
spider powers still
so it's not like they can't be called
back into action and i have a suspicion
if this movie makes money
they will be but this will be tom
holland's sixth appearance
as spider-man so it stands to reason
he'll be looking for a reason
to pass the torch so i believe that this
movie is going to be all about
uh returning home returning to your
roots and and uh going back to a normal
life
while passing on the the the great title
of spider-man
amongst the spider-man i rest my case oh
wow
that's interesting i wonder where a
trial of peter parker would be held
in new york or in london where they have
those weird barristers who still wear
the wigs
uh because either way
uh there will be wigs involved that's
all i can say
my sources are saying the wig budget on
this movie is phenomenal
it's all going to kristen wig in that
cat costume from wonder woman kristen
wiig will be crossing over also
weirdly and it's a pretty big crossover
they spent so much money on that weird
costume that they got a user in as many
properties as possible
they're loading it they're just putting
it on like a museum piece she's just
going to different
she'll be in the new fantastic beasts
movie as well oh wow that's gonna be
great
yeah yeah i i think our viewers might be
over this crossover
no tommy i i really like your idea what
you
say kind of recalls the ancient one
saying to doctor strange when he was
zipping through the multiverse like who
are you
in this vast multiverse and as soon as
like any spider-verse crosses over
that is kind of like the natural
conversation right like how
i don't own the title of spider-man none
of us own the title of spider-man
because we're all
part of a multiverse uh so
isn't it right that someone now takes
over for me to take the heat off of me
and who better than someone who has
loyally defended me uh the miles morales
and i think that's where everything
is headed like sony obviously loves the
character of miles morales
it was so profitable for them and into
the spider-verse they have a miles
morales game coming out
that's gonna be uh what they're gonna be
banking on and it's such a cool
character like why not yeah let's go for
it
um and tommy what would you call this
because we know home is probably gonna
be in the title somewhere what's your
home
title spider-man home
team advantage
very nice yes well done tommy i am going
to
award you uh three uh rogue points for
that theory all right
excellent uh well you'll be shocked to
hear
they appear on my end as a uh signed
mick foley sock
uh from the wwe universe that i have had
sitting out for three years uh let's see
what else i got here
uh these are just things that are
literally on my desk i have a
uh signed dvd uh copy of ghostbusters by
ernie hudson
still cool my my favorite ghostbuster uh
of all time and of course finally uh
let's just see here uh
the third rogi came in as a joey gallow
baseball card uh negative side actor
tops chrome
not signed not signed not interested not
acknowledged
uh by joey at all he doesn't even know i
own it
uh yes you better give it back um all
right
uh let's move on jessica how do you
think these spider-verses are going to
be colliding what do you think the plot
of spider-man 3 is going to be
tom holland andrew garfield and toby
mcguire
i think those three are going to come
back into spider-man 3. how they would
come into spider-man 3 is they're gonna
what marvel likes to do because what
disney wants to do is
make money ultimately and get as much
views on stuff they have to connect
properties correct think about it and so
they have one division coming out right
so what if scarlet witch when she has
her meltdown and she creates all these
different portals around the world which
would also
coincide with the new doctor strange it
also goes into the universe
that is spider-man and all of the
superheroes start coming out of the
portals
some of the super villains including
electro they come back out
and the three spider-man that come out
are toby maguire
we could also get obviously spider-gwen
we could also get
weird doc awk when he was like the
superior spider-man
we could get different versions of
spider-man all coming into this universe
so i think it's gonna be tom holland
spider-man
fighting off all of these villains
electro being kind of
not like the not like the um the leader
of all the villains
i think he's just gonna be like the
number one like militant one
and that's gonna be his his like the
villain that he's gonna go against
but they're also gonna have to fight all
the other ones imagine i guess
inside the spider verse but a live
action one whereas because if we were
gonna get into it eventually
why not do it now like tommy said we've
had a sixth appearance
why not bring back all of the stuff that
the fans want
and just throw it in here because we
have the time to do it what else are we
doing
and if that doesn't work i think those
three those two
other spider-man could come back in a
fun little fan cameo appearance
where it's three spider-men all pointing
at each other and it's revealed that
it's
tom holland toby mcguire and andrew
garfield
and the fans would say they have to do
yeah it's like if they don't put them in
the entire movie which i
hey i understand as a fan i would love
that ultimately with the story line it
might not line up
but if they don't do that they have to
oh my god they have to bring them back
all three of them pointing at each other
in a fun cameo
and i mean they did it with jj we could
or triple j
we can do with this we can do it here
yeah and i think you're you're
definitely right jessica like people say
like oh no they'll save that for later
i think all these studios are saying we
don't know how much longer
superhero movies are gonna be popular
like we
like you know for the past 20 years or
so yeah they have been the thing
but like it's obviously not gonna last
forever so they're gonna cash in
on live-action spider-verses sooner
rather than later i totally agree
especially since we're in like a
pandemic and we have this big gap right
now
on the other side of it they're gonna
want to try to win back as many viewers
in uh to cinemas as they possibly can um
and and into the spider-verse they had
the um the plot mechanic was the
collider right like kingpin
was trying to bring back his family
bringing using wanda vision
as the means i think is is a pretty
accurate way they could do it because
one division is one mcu property
we know is going to be coming out before
spider-man 3 coming out way before
a year exactly like a year yeah i think
using wanda's reality warping using that
like um
that television screen portal that
monica rambo is going through could be
one way because we know that's like
through different media right like going
through a tv screen
it's just something that uh visual
aesthetic audiences will get
uh and i think like we know that things
like agents of shield even though it's
not mcu proper
are still using things like the mcu
quantum realm they can still use
elements of the mcu just to justify
their own stories i can totally see
sony absolutely they can do everything
they want and they i was reading
somewhere where they were like
the disney plus properties are going to
be more tied in
with the movies that come out just like
the bigger movies are going straight to
theaters
so they were like you're going to need
to start in the future watching all of
the shows that are going to be released
on disney plus
in order to connect all of the movies to
it too yeah so i was just like yeah this
makes complete sense especially because
we're getting into the world where we're
now recognizing the multiverse more
wanda has to be like
a main component of it yeah all right
jessica for tying
in wanda vision into the logic of
spider-man 3 i'm awarding you
four rogy points
it came to me in some sticky notes that
go
the opposite direction it came to me
in a lid for my mason jar
and a hand sanitizer and lastly
candlesticks for three dollars from
target
this is autographed by wwe wrestlers
because
oh i wish i wish i'm sorry
i'm not as cool as tommy we'll see if
you can get one of them on the line and
maybe we can get something going all
right john it's your turn
uh what do you think this spider-man 3
spider-verse thing
is doing what's the real story going on
here i think the most important thing is
the fact that
you know depending on how old you are
you have like your own spider-man
i'm old enough to be a tobey maguire
spider-man guy so much so that i spent
many years
avoiding the amazing spider-man movies
because i was like this is not my
spider-man
this is you are not toby maguire andrew
garfield
um and it's taking me a while to warm up
to tom
so you know okay i think what
what they're really gonna do is they're
just gonna just bring them all back
together
and you initially would think oh well
just a good old-fashioned
team em up you know with all the
spider-man no they're gonna be fighting
each other
because you don't expect it you don't
expect you know good old tobey mcguire
like coming in and just being like you
know what no i don't like you
tom holland i don't like you andrew
garfield and for whatever
reason i think they're all going to be
fighting each other and i think that
will
be just really different than what you
expect and this is marvel's way of
saying
hey we can have a superhero versus
superhero
movie that's not terrible batman v
superman and i think that
just everyone who's ever seen spider-man
like this is my favorite one
and also you gotta just make it
different than into the spider verse you
gotta just like mix it up a little bit
get a little darker you know maybe one
of them is gonna die
especially one of the ones who's not tom
like
wouldn't really affect them that much if
andrew garfield died and actually would
make me a little happy probably not
that's spiderman
it'd make a lot of us pretty happy never
toby
um no i think you're definitely onto
something john i mean that is
like one thing we forget we've seen so
much cooperation in the mcu
but like part of the fun of some of
these earlier films are seeing these
heroes fight
and have sparring sessions and you know
uh fighting in forests
and i want more fighting in forests i
mean when you see
your your duplicate your doppelganger in
some kind of multiverse crossover as we
saw with the two different versions of
captain american endgame
we wanna see um fight there can only be
one and like
or in that movie coherence can you guys
see coherence coherence is a crazy one
um
but it has deals with like schrodinger's
cats stuff
and uh and and i think you're you're
gonna see people be like
i don't want my universe to disappear so
i have to destroy you
oh sure uh no yeah i think we definitely
need to see some fighting going on
and uh if that could last the whole
movie sure i'm i'm on board for it
john i am awarding you three
uh roggy points for your theory i've
decorated my apartment
for the fall so i've got a lot of
decorative pumpkins
we've got this guy right here
we've got a little gold whoa
well let us know down in the comments
below what version of the spider-verse
you think we're going to be seeing
because yeah we're definitely we already
have a spider-verse we already have j
jonah jameson in multiple universes we
already have
easter eggs connecting from the mcu back
to the raimi verse
so like how are they gonna heighten this
and how how is it logically gonna work
i you know i i'd love to see one
divisions uh
warping i'd also just love to see sticky
patches open on a wall and characters
crawl through it all sticky covered in
goo
the weirder the better honestly so pitch
your theories and comments below
uh but we want to move on to some people
who helped us make this episode
first we want to thank our friends at
bespoke post for sponsoring this episode
so this fall as you get back into the
swing of things
hopefully bespoke post has a brand new
seasonal box of awesome collections for
guys
guaranteed to upgrade your life and pass
bespoke post boxes i've gotten cool
gadgets
fun drink mixes uh one of my favorite
shirts
whether it's gear to upgrade your autumn
craft beers or cozy threads for when the
temperature dips bespoke post only sends
guys the best stuff every month no
matter what you're into box of awesome
has you covered from style and grooming
goods to bar wear box of awesome has
collections for every part of your life
their new uber easy box comes with a
cast iron skillet
pancake mix bloody mary mix and pure
vermont
maple syrup which sounds like a nice
sunday morning or the beginning
of my apocalypse survival kit either way
i'll be starting my day
buzzed to get started take the quiz at
box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over
70 dollars worth of gear inside get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com
and enter the code rogue checkout that's
box of awesome dot com
code rogue r-o-g-u-e for 20
off your first box we also want to thank
our friends at expressvpn
for sponsoring this okay so we all know
how vpn protects your privacy and
security online right but
maybe you didn't know that you can use a
vpn to unlock
movies and shows that are only available
in other countries
you can go nuts binging doctor who on
the uk version of netflix
or anime on the japanese version of
netflix it's just really simple
all you gotta do fire up the expressvpn
app change your location to one of those
other countries refresh netflix and
that's it
you're practically there expressvpn
hides your ip address and lets you
control where you want sites to think
you're located you can
choose from almost 100 different
countries so just think about all the
netflix libraries you can go through
and it's not just netflix expressvpn
works with any streaming service hulu
bbc iplayer
youtube you name it you can watch new
rockstars videos while pretending you
live in brazil just to feel like you're
traveling
there are hundreds of vpns out there but
the reason i use expressvpn to watch
shows is it
is ridiculously fast there is never any
buffering or lag
and you can stream hd no problem
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices
iphones media consoles smart tvs more
you can watch what you want on the go
or on the big screen wherever you are if
you visit my special link right now
expressvpn.com rogue you can get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free
support the show watch what you want and
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
rogue and lastly we gotta thank our
friends at
manscaped for sponsoring this video
my friends fall weather means sweaters
and scarves and wool hats but not
wool downstairs if you know what i mean
i'm not talking socks
upstairs a little bit there you are
pubes get rid of them
with a shaver our sponsor today
manscaped
has you covered to keep your downstairs
less downy
so manscaped offers precision engineered
tools
for your family jewels we here at new
rockstars love our prince at midscape
we love getting to make ridiculous
double entendres during the ads and we
especially love their products
which keep us feeling good and looking
good without injuring ourselves
the manscaped engineering team just
perfected the greatest
ball hair trimmer ever created it's
called the lawnmower
3.0 do you hear that purr it's like a
kitten
the premium lawnmower 3.0 is waterproof
it includes this led light
and it is made with the advanced skin
safe technology which reduces
nicks and cuts on your delicates you can
get this trimmer
inside their perfect package 3.0 which
includes the manscape crop preserver
ball deodorant
and the crop reviver ball toning spray
plus
for a limited time when you order the
perfect package kit you get
two free gifts the shed travel bag and
the manscaped anti-chafing boxer briefs
the manscape boxer briefs which i am
wearing right now
have optimal temperature control with
their crop cooling technology
the same stuff frosty that snowman uses
to maintain his man ice
we can't verify that we're just assuming
you
need to try this out for yourself and
tweet tommy all about it after you do
get send in pictures uh graphic detail
get 20 off at get 20 off and free
shipping with the code roguetheory at
manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code rogue theory
from the moose to the caboose always use
the right tools for the job
all right we're going to move on to our
discord rogue theory a quick shout out
to our patron
mr mosby who won this week's discord
rogue theory with an
awesome pitch for a new disney plus show
built around the backstory of mcu
villain
dr doom doctor doom is a title we want
to see very soon on the mcu and mr mosby
rightfully understands that you cannot
do that just with a movie
you need an episodic structure to build
up to that there's just so much of
character development
we need amazing theory well done mr
mosby
and you can read his theory and other
pitches and play discord rogue theory
yourself by becoming a patron
of new rockstars at patreon.com new
rockstars
but we got to get back to talking about
the spider-man movie that
jamie fox electro is joining because in
addition to fox there are reports that
sony might be considering returns
by kirsten dunst mary jane watson from
the twin maguire sam raimi spider-man
films
as well as dane dahan harry osborne
green goblin from
the amazing spiderman wow
um look folks it sounds like everything
is on the table so i want to know from
you what other
past spider-man villain do you want to
see return in spider-man 3 and why
john why don't we start with you here
listen i have four words for you
will lump the foe
four words all right iconic
spider-man villain all right that's all
i want i don't care about anybody else
showing up
all i need is the original green goblin
i need willem dafoe for two hours just
chewing that scenery
just doing his thing
oh my iconic any super villain
after 2000 is just trying to do their
best willem dafoe
in the original spiderman that's a very
good point that he was so inspirational
and
look john even if he is just in a mirror
talking to other characters or he's a
portrait who is talking that's i just
need his voice
back in these movies absolutely
absolutely and i would love it if people
just look in the mirror and there's
willem dafoe
that's an amazing film in and of itself
if you say will of defoe those four
words into a mirror three times you
will see i've i'm i'm
confident i'm too afraid to do it myself
but let me know if you're watching help
oh i'm not going to try it that's too
scary for me
it's too scary yeah it's it's halloween
season it's too scary
um john for your four amazing words i'm
giving you
four points it was
uh arguably and it was well defended
i'm about to i'm about to choose the
same topic
all right well jessica is your pitch uh
norman osborne do you have a dude
you know what i have another one oh you
know what else
i truly that was my my first one is what
i was going with right now second one
was the wonderful and now i kind of want
to go back to wollonfell it makes sense
but no i will go with mine so so
i think a villain that we should bring
back is doc ock but instead of the doc
that we saw in the original we're gonna
get katherine hahn playing
live octavius and i'm very excited for
the idea of this
because yeah she's gonna be and i'm
bringing it up again because i
love wanda vision yeah she's gonna be in
a wanda vision
yes we all know that but that would be
so great if i can't get that damn cameo
with tom holland andrew garfield and
toby maguire i want that katherine han
as octavia as doc ock and it would be so
fun if it's just it's just kathryn hahn
it was the voice of liv
and into the spider verse and she comes
through in that exact outfit with the
hair pinned up like a beehive
and i'd be so into it and she wouldn't
turn him away awesome
i'm also a root for anything catherine
hansen uh she's my willem dafoe she is
yeah oh man i i think that would be
fantastic and she is one of the
because all the voice actors for into
the spider-verse were pretty incredible
i'd love to see
jake johnson play a live-action role in
the mc as well but
oh you showed up with like the
sweatpants i'd be so happy
yeah yeah let's get nick miller in there
but um let's go
catherine han is such a great actress
and i got to say from a personal level
when i first moved to la and i was a
intern at my improv theater io west i
worked thursday nights a lot i met
a couple famous people they all blew me
off she was one who had she got there
early she's in the green room
putting on her makeup and i was like so
you have 10 minutes and she was so sweet
to me she's the first famous person i
met i just seen step brothers
and her in parks and rec and it was the
first time like a famous person was
really really nice to me and i was like
i wish you nothing but success and she's
had nothing but success she's been
amazing
she's amazing she's my mama i wish you
would be
um so i'm going to give you uh three
points jessica for your katherine han
pitch
thank you all right tommy bring us home
yes who do you want to see come back
five syllables for you toe fur
grace please daddy toe for grace says
venom
coming back no i'm just kidding uh
i have to change mine on the fly because
mine was also mine was also willem dafoe
so
so i i think logically the person
with the most like what the hell were
they supposed to do we never really got
a fulfilling uh portrayal of the
characters paul giamatti is rhino
let's get rhino seriously yeah what an
incredible what an incredible actor that
was
used as basically set up and then
like conclusion-ish cliffhanger at the
end of the amazing spider-man
2 like we're we're owed more of that
rhino character
if we're gonna have electro come back
why not have rhino come back
and uh you know maybe as a team maybe as
uh
two people in cahoots maybe the old
electric rhino as i say
which is usually what i just call my
manscape uh
no we're not done with that spot i call
it the old electric rhino because it's
always in charge
give him zero
um i have to say i just re-watched the
clip of the chris gether
show where it was uh what's in the
dumpster or one man's trash is the name
of the episode
and it's it's very interesting um i
guess i'm about to spoil it
so if you you really should go watch
this episode go watch it right now if
you ever cared about watching it pause
it go watch it come back
where they bring in the dumpster they're
like something is in this dumpster and
you have to guess what it is and they
had people guessing guessing guess
and at one point um uh they the other
guests who are on the show was like um
i'm this character i'm not sure if this
actor is
in the marvel universe and then uh chris
gathered asks are you in the marvel
universe
uh bang on the lid once and the person
did and then later
it was revealed to be paul giamatti and
then everyone's kind of confused they're
like wait are you in the marvel universe
i think they were trying to say are you
in the mcu and he had just been in the
amazing spider-man 2
but like the reason i re-watched it i
was like did giamatti know
something did giamatti whis did he have
a meeting with kevin feige and he's like
one day we're going to get you back in
this universe studio matz and he's like
i'll remember that so holy baby
i do love paul giamatti but i got to say
tommy i kind of loved your topher grace
venom
theory he yeah well that would be under
appreciated in that role
he could have been great but him as
venom
up against tom hardy as venom as like
venom multiverse venoms
would be truly incredible
really hilarious uh tommy but
uh i'm sorry i have to give you two
rogies just because you gotta
excite you went with a lesser excited so
you get two i'll
i'll take two all right um all right
everybody
uh i believe our scores are john was
seven jessica was seven tommy with five
jessica believes he has two uh that's
because she's mad at the knuckle
that's fair uh well here's our chance
it's still anybody's game because we
have one final
rogue question for you three it's just
in time for halloween uh the
pennsylvania house
used as buffalo bills house and silence
of the lambs is reportedly
up for sale so in honor of the only
horror movie to win a best picture oscar
which is a shame because there's been so
many great ones but this one definitely
deserved it
i would like you to give me from silence
of the lambs
the best buffalo bill or the best
hannibal lecter
impression i'll i'll go first i'll go
first so this is what uh
this is buffalo bill at his open house
for
his house for sale sure she's a bit of a
fixer-upper
but it's a buyer's market you'd be a
fool not to put a bid
in are you like a great big fat person
because this house is massive
there's a pit in the ground you could
use as a bathtub if you are like a size
12.
come into my house put the lotion on
it's very cold outside and we're all
using too much sanitizer
on our hands so put the lotion on the
hands so you can sanitize again
wow well done i should have not let
tommy go first
big mistake wow well i'm definitely not
going second
i will go second before i do what will
be
a terrible impression i will say that
early in my sketch writing career
i wrote a sketch called silence of the
lamb chops
and it was yes it was a sketch about a
times square restaurant
next to bubblegum shrimp that was called
the side of the lamb chops and it was a
silence of the lambs themed
restaurant and it was oh my god maybe
the worst thing i've ever written
it was before
[Laughter]
[Music]
well done yes yes yes i will also do
buffalo bill
uh impersonating him on his youtube
channel
where he tests out the newest makeup
cosmetics
welcome to my channel again uh like and
don't forget to like and subscribe
if you want a more refreshing feel on
your face i would
recommend the trader joe's rose water
vision facial skin
it refreshes your skin as much as my
lotion that i started making at home
myself you just don't know
put it on your skin as long as you're a
size 16 or higher
uh well i'm feeling generous um john i
want to start with you
uh for your sketch pitch alone uh for a
sense of the lamb chops
you get one rogi point for that well
done that brings you to a total of eight
uh tommy you had an amazing impression
way to work in a lot of references
including great big fat person uh
uh yeah at the hole in the basement yeah
you get it so you're gonna get two ruggy
points
bringing you a total of seven uh but
just
for jessica for understanding the medium
is the message here and doing a youtube
take on it you get
another one to bringing you uh up to
a total of eight uh so does that deserve
12 deserved
uh so that makes our winners we have
some co-winners uh right yes you both
were at eight
uh jessica and john uh well done this
episode
um so i guess for uh our winner
or our victory dance we'll be doing the
dance from goodbye horses and styles of
lamps so tommy weeps because he can't
join us
so we'll do that through the end of the
episode yeah if you want to sing that as
i do the goodbyes
[Laughter]
well that is this week's episode of
rogue theory
uh i want to thank all of our guests
this week all three are wonderful
tommy bechtold jessica clemens
and john xavier miller follow them all
on their social medias
they're uh three hilarious people who
have
all kinds of amazing projects that
you're gonna want to check out by
following them wherever they are
uh don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory podcast feed stay tuned to the
youtube channel for this and other
shows i'm eric boss you can follow me at
eavos uh join us on twitter at new
rockstars
join us on discord by uh becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars
and goodbye horses
[Music]
bye